every Thursday we highlight stories
affecting consumers across the country
new tests reveal popular cereals and
snacks could have potentially dangerous
levels of the same chemical found in
weedkiller
it's called glyphosate and some reports
say it may cause cancer of the 21
General Mills products examined by the
Environmental Working Group the highest
levels of glyphosate were found in honey
nut cheerios medley crunch it had more
than five times what the advocacy group
considers a safe level original cheerios
had more than four and a half times what
the group believes is a safe level the
products are considered safe under EPA
standards General Mills released a
statement that says in part these are
very strict rules that we follow as do
farmers who grow crops we continue to
work closely with farmers our suppliers
and conservation organizations to
minimize the use of pesticides on the
ingredients we use in our foods the
maker of roundup weed killer says the
glyphosate levels in this report are
quote far below the established safety
standards we also reached out to the EPA
and the FDA but have not heard back our
dr. David agus is a cancer specialist
and he joins us now so the Environmental
Working Group the advocacy organization
says this is too much glyphosate other
organizations say it's not bottom line
should we be taking a risk with this in
our cereal the bottom line is we just
don't know and the problem is is when
you eat something say glyphosate there's
a 10 20 year lag between disease and the
intervention so glyphosate came about in
the 60s it was meant to clean pipes
originally and then it was a weed killer
and it was used but not dramatically but
then in the 90s GMO food came out and
Roundup Ready crops which meant you can
kill all the weeds but not the crops the
usage went through the roof would you
put it in your body if you had a choice
I certainly wouldn't you know everyone
asks me that and what we know is it can
kill bacteria in your GI tract it could
disrupt your endocrine system and
there's reasonable data that it can
increase risk of lymphoma so based on
all of those is probably not good and in
the last couple of years more and more
farms across the world or using it to
kill all of their crops right before
harvest so it's easier to
servus so the levels of going up
dramatically in the last decade how does
it actually get into like our Cheerios
and other oat oat based foods you said
that would love changes don't mess with
my cheer I saw it in your eyes
so they spray the crops right before
Harbor so they're all killed at once and
dries out the crop and they can harvest
it but that's a lot of chemical on the
crops the crops are processed and it's
in our foods and so this is something
that we're measuring now in the urine of
most people in the country you can find
glyphosate and so this chemical disrupts
our body it affects the bacteria in our
GI tract it affects our hormone levels
and affects many of the cells in our
body how it affects disease we're not
going to know for another 10 years
because the real uses was in the last
decade the manufacturer of the
glyphosate based weed killer told CBS
News the reality is that regulatory
authorities have strict rules when it
comes to pesticide residues and the
levels in this report are far below the
established safety standards should
farmers be looking for an alternative
here I think we have to go and we have
to re-examine farming yes the farmer who
doesn't use glyphosate is at a
competitive disadvantage to his or her
neighbor who does use it so we have to
figure out better and safer ways of
doing it the FDA regulations they just
changed the rules you know about 10 plus
years ago to actually lower the rate of
glyphosate that's allowed you may raise
the rate of life or that's allowed in
food we have to re-examine this and I
think with everything we have to look
and say are there better ways of growing
hydroponics no insecticides and
pesticides maybe we need to move in that
direction new things have to be done we
may need some pesticides around here
we've got to fly I'm sad about this get
him take them dr. David agus thank you
very much if you want to see a full list
of all 21 products that were tested
visit our website that is cBS This
Morning Calm